good morning John this is going to be on
the last video before I go and return it
Ely done I wouldn't say that I'm
addicted to work I probably should it's
gonna be weird to take a break I don't
know what that's gonna be like I haven't
taken a break from doing this in 10
years I started making YouTube videos
when I was 26 years old I'm 36 Wow whoa
but in all honesty I'm a little worried
about my ability to disengage but before
I leave you all I have some housekeeping
I've made two videos that will upload
during paternity leave I've already made
them and uploaded them and scheduled
them one is a promo video for VidCon
that will go up as soon as tickets go on
sale in Australia Amsterdam and the u.s.
they're already on sale in the US
Australia and Amsterdam will be coming
soon second I will be on leave during
Pizza miss which I feel bad about
because the entire idea of Pizza misses
that we make more videos than usual and
I'm gonna miss it so I made one then
we're having people cover me for the
other ones but I wanted to talk a little
bit about Pizza mist is here because
it's a little bit different in terms of
our design this year I decided to reach
out to a bunch of my favorite designers
on the internet and ask them for their
take on Pizza John which has resulted in
a very diverse and weird group of Pizza
John designs that I'm very excited about
sharing with people I'm wearing Pizza
John hoodie right now that you can't buy
yet but they shouldn't even be showing
you I'm also wearing a pizza John design
under here because I was just making
that video if you're not supposed to be
seeing these things about you're not
supposed to be seeing that this hoodie
has that thing oh yeah these are all our
tests print room there's a pile of Pizza
John shirts behind the camera staring at
me literally very excited to unleash
them upon the world and also I really
like the video I made so that's been
canon piece um it's also project for
awesome is coming up I won't be able to
talk about that much before the project
for awesome happens so get your project
for awesome in hands ready and if you
don't know what that is you can Google
done maybe you want to make a video
about that I know it's probably my turn
to do that sorry I think last piece of
housekeeping is that I will be trying to
disengage from social media which will
be very hard for minimum and try to not
tweet at all there will be people
tweeting as me I think mostly Victorious
to let people know about things that are
happening whether that's project for
awesome or VidCon or Pete's miss or
whatever but I like creating content on
my social media and there won't be any
of that because I'm gonna try my best
not to do it so I've scheduled some
tweets for the future just so that
there'll be something coming out in
there hashtag to pre tweet but I can't
come up with six weeks worth of tweets
so I'm asking you all to help me leave
down below ideas for things that you
would like me to tweet and have them to
be about a hundred and
characters so we can tack them and also
maybe tag you if you want to leave your
Twitter handle there the weird thing
happened to me today I got this in the
mail it's a Google pixel phone now I
want to be clear I'm an iPhone user I
have no particular affinity for any kind
of phone but they did send this to me
because it's YouTube is Google and it's
the related thing and I am gonna give
this to my favorite tweet it's the Excel
version it's got 128 gigabytes inside of
it I don't know how they fit that many
in there I don't believe in upgrading a
phone just because somebody sends you a
thousand dollar phone I'm gonna send it
to one of you here it is hmm I kissed it
you gotta leave your Twitter handle so
that we can find you and I'm gonna put a
Hank or fish on the back of this so now
there's that and I bet whoever gets this
is gonna need it more than me and again
this is not a sponsorship I do not
endorse that phone I know nothing about
it choose whatever phone you would like
to choose as long as it isn't one of the
exploding ones and I think that's it I
think I'm gonna in this video and then
I'm gonna go on paternity leave it's a
thing that's actually gonna happen
John I'll see you on Tuesday you'll see
me whenever you come visit ones that you
come to visit you should do that